okay I'm gonna start with feyo's I'm
most excited for the audience to learn
about him I think it's very interesting
and complex villain that's why I like
them that's why I'm excited for the
audience to learn about him I think his
motivations albeit psychotic are
compelling and and I think that that
this in a lot of ways is his movie so
it's gonna be very interesting to see
how people respond to fans in song baby
the star is in your blood
hey everybody Thanos is coming and they
finally revealed what his true name is
in the comics there's a deeper meaning
to it and it's somewhat ironic based on
the way that the Russo brothers teed him
up psychotic but with a very specific
vision for the universe since he was
created his most popular name was
probably the mad Titan but he's also
been called master Thanos Rex master
Lord / Master all-father because way
back during a celestial quest storyline
he had the power of the all-father but
then there are other comedy names that
the Avengers call him like Chin's but
his true name in the comics is Dion and
it's a name from Greek mythology it's
the name of one of the Greek titans but
the reason for the reveal is is because
of this comic book storyline where two
different versions of fan o's are trying
to deal with each other and one of them
has to prove that he really is a future
version of himself so if you ever wanted
to know how hardcore Thanos was he
killed his own mother suisse and she had
whispered it to him as he was getting
ready to kill her
so if there was ever any doubt about how
hardcore Thanos was he killed his own
mother a very severe form of mercy
because she'd been driven mad by the
very act of his birth so she had these
great hopes for him she named him Dion
in the thing about the name is is that
it's actually the Greek Titan who was
the mother of Aphrodite the mother of
the idea of love so it was like this
idea that he would bring great love into
the universe which he has albeit in a
very sarcastic way so when the Russos in
infinity war are talking about how he
has this very compelling plan for the
universe but you look at any of the
Avengers here and they'll tell you that
he's out of his goddamn mind you plan to
do what you plan to kill
of all life in the universe so most of
you are familiar with Thanos's comic
book story in how he's tasked by death
to balance the universe the only thing
that we really don't know is how death
as a character figures into this because
there's this long-standing tradition in
the comics that he is in love with death
he has this ongoing relationship with
her sometimes it's a love-hate
relationship like he hates her is
terrified of her is always betrayed by
her but like any abusive relationship
cannot stop loving her in fact one of
the funny reveals is that his older
Thanos is revealing his true name to his
younger self it's because he's trying to
convince him to help rescue death
because the older version of Thanos is
alive at the end of time in his immortal
he's unable to die so it's almost like
he's trying to get his younger self to
help bring death back into the universe
so that he can eventually die because
he's been ruling a dead universe for
millions of years
so Thanos might love being king of the
universe for maybe a thousand years but
imagine ruling over absolutely nothing
for millions of years with nothing but a
Ghost Rider to keep you company
you would be driven insane he truly
would become the mad Titan but even if
they've changed the way that the
character death works during the next
two Avengers films Thanos his quest is
of his great love for the balance of the
universe so he's one of those type of
dictator psychos that has this crazy
idea for order and is going about it and
the most efficient means possible which
means erasing half of all life in the
universe
but what are the Russos talking about
when they say that he has a very
compelling reason for that like you know
why is it that you're supposed to
sympathize with Thanos in the movie
because he's the main star and I think
it has something to do with more of like
a meta contextual way of explaining how
things go on for too long sometimes and
you need to let things die so that new
things can grow in their place so what
is one of the biggest complaints about
big Marvel movies you can't kill the big
characters because their franchises and
they make too much money because even
though they're doing the comic book
storyline in during that deaths reason
for asking fan OHS to balance the
universe was because there were more
people alive than had ever died in the
history of existence so she
like that is a great cosmic imbalance
you need to fix that get rid of a whole
bunch of people for me and then Thanos
eventually realizes that he doesn't need
to be anybody's finger puppet he has the
power of a god once he wields the
infinity gems so that's where it kind of
goes off the rails but you can kind of
see in a way that they're using that to
explain some of the issues with
storytelling in phase 1 phase 2 phase 3
like Oh none of the heroes none of the
big characters ever wind up dying Thanos
is gonna make sure that that changes but
we should also say you know giant
asterisk there will be a lot of people
that walk out of this into phase 4 like
we know that spider-man is getting
another movie right after Avengers 4
there's no way he's gonna die
we know the guardians are getting their
third film so most of them will still be
alive but I'm really interested to see
if they're willing to take the meta
commentary that far and say you know
what Iron Man Captain America the a-list
Avengers that started it all they're the
ones that are on the chopping block
right now with the exception of like
brief funny cameos like Tony Stark
turning himself into an artificial
intelligence so that you still have
Robert Downey jr. potentially around
even if they decide to kill him off
during the next two Avengers films but
let me know what you think about the
irony of Thanos original name that he
was meant to bring great love into the
universe in a really twisted way he does
love the universe but the only thing
that he is loyal to is death itself
anything else
he'll throw right onto the bus because
he was even willing to kill all of his
own natural born children at death's
behest but you know I know people are
asking about the actual children of
Thanos during infinity war that's who
the Black Order is like when Gamora and
nebula talked about being children of
Thanos the black order are the other
children that they grew up with as a
child my father would have Gamora and me
battle one another in training every
time my sister prevailed
my father would replace a piece of me
with machinery
claiming he wanted me to be her equal
but she won again and again and again
never once refraining so after I murder
my sister I will buy a warship with
every conceivable instrument of death I
will hunt my father like a dog and I
will tear him apart slowly piece by
piece until he knows some semblance of
the profound and unceasing pain I know
every single yeah so like even though
Proxima midnight looks like she's been
heavily modified you look at her skin
and she actually looks like she's from
the same race as nebula was like they
had that same blue skin even though they
have all these prosthetics and changes
that Thanos has made to them to make
them stronger but a lot of you have made
a request for a black order video so I
will do something about that separately
in the next couple of weeks there'll be
a bunch of infinity war dropping as we
ramp up into black panther so separately
there'll be a lot of new Black Panther
and infinity war really soon but just
leave all your requests in the comments
below but there's a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet replica giveaway all
you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber share the video using those
YouTube tools on the watch page
congratulations to the winner from my
last video Moonfire links please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for more new Black
Panther and click here for more infantry
war thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]